>> Sean: SO NOW AFTER
ENDURING YET ANOTHER
BASELESS SMEAR FROM THE
CORRUPT MOB AND THE MEDIA.
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES IS
TAKING IMMEDIATE ACTION
FILING A BOMBSHELL
DEFAMATION LAWSUIT AGAINST
CNN AFTER THEY PUBLISH
ALLEGED FALSE STORY ABOUT
NUNES TRAVELING TO VIENNA TO
DIG UP DIRT ON QUID PRO QUO
JOE.
NOW TODAY'S FILING IS
EXPLOSIVE AND EXPOSES JUST
HOW WRONG CNN GOT.
THIS AND JUST HOW LOW THEY
WILL SINK TO TRY AND SMEAR A
DULY ELECTED MEMBER OF
CONGRESS AND, OF COURSE, THE
CONGENITAL LIAR ADAM SCHIFF
IS NOT ONLY CONTINUING TO
STEER DEMOCRATS OFF THE
IMPEACHMENT CLIFF, BUT HE IS
APPARENTLY PROMOTING THE
SMEAR EFFORT AS WELL
ALLEGING THE CALL LEG SHOWED
DEVIN NUNES GIULIANI DIG UP
DIRT ON UKRAINE.
HERE IS DEVIN NUNES.
START WITH THE LAWSUIT.
EVER TRAVEL TO VENTRICLENA,
CONGRESSMAN.
>> I HAVE BEEN TO VIENNA I
WASN'T THERE IN 2018 WHEN
THEY SAID I WAS THERE.
THAT'S THEIR PROBLEM.
>> Sean: LET'S TALK ABOUT
THE SPECIFICS OF WHAT THEY
GOT WRONG AND HERE IS THE
OTHER QUESTION.
THEY DO ANY DUE DILIGENCE.
EVER ASK YOU OR YOUR OFFICE?
>> LOOK, HERE IS MY
>> LOOK, HERE IS RY
>> LOOK, HERE IS RULE FOR
CNN THE LAST TWO AND A HALF
YEARS AND MOST OF THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
MOST OF CAPITAL HERE UNTIL
AND THEY KNOW IT UNTIL THEY
RETRACT FAKE NEWS STORIES
ABOUT ME BEING UNDER
INVESTIGATION AND DOING
MIDNIGHT RUNS TO THE WHITE
HOUSE UNTIL YOU RETRACT I'M
NOT ACKNOWLEDGING ANY
QUESTION THAT YOU GIVE TO ME
IN THIS LIFETIME OR THE NEXT
LIFETIME.
SO THEY KNOW THAT I DON'T
RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS.
I DON'T EVEN ACKNOWLEDGE
QUESTIONS.
RIGHT?
BUT WHEN THEY SAID THAT I
WAS IN VIENNA, I WAS
ACTUALLY IN BENGHAZI.
I WAS THE FIRST MEMBER OF
CONGRESS TO BE BACK IN
BENGHAZI SINCE AFTER THE
ATTACKS MEETING WITH GENERAL
HAFTAR THEN FROM THERE TO
MALTA TO PARTICIPATE NATE A
REPATRIATATION CEREMONY WE
FOUND A SOLDIER IN THE
MEDITERRANEAN.
WE HAD THE REMAINS OF THE
SOLDIER SO HE COULD BE
LOADED BACK UP ON A PLANE
AND SHIPPED BACK TO THE
UNITED STATES.
I WAS NOT MEETING WITH
UKRAINIANS IN VIENNA IN
DECEMBER OF 2018.
IT WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN HARD
TO PROVE.
AND I THINK THE BIGGER POINT
HERE, SEAN, IS THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T BE LISTENING TO
SOMEBODY WHO HAS BEEN
INDICTED, OKAY?
IT'S REALLY REALLY BAD ON
THEIR PART.
IT'S RECKLESS.
IT'S CLEARLY RECKLESS.
AND, LOOK, IT'S BEEN 10
DAYS.
I WAS ON -- THIS STORY CAME
OUT 10 DAYS AGO.
I WAS VERY CLEAR.
I SAID IT WAS DEMONSTRABLY
FALSE.
CLEAR DEFINITION THAT I WAS
DENYING IT.
THEY DIDN'T CORRECT THE
RECORD.
I WENT ON YOUR SHOW AND SAID
A WEEK AGO THAFS GOING TO BE
WORKING ALL WEEK TO GET ALL
THE FACTS TO PRESENCE THEM
IN FEDERAL COURT.
SO LOOK I'M READY TO MEET
WITH CNN TOMORROW.
THEY CAN PUT ALL THE FACTS
ON THE TABLE.
I WILL PUT ALL MY FACTS ON
THE TABLE AND WE NEED TO GO
TO A JURY TRIAL AND LET A
JURY DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT
WHAT'S BEEN DONE HERE IS
APPROPRIATE.
IT'S CLEAR TO ME CNN HAS HAD
AN AX TO GRIND.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE YOU SEEN
IT, SEAN?
YOU HAVE SEEN IT, YOUR
VIEWERS HAVE SEEN IT.
CNN CHASING ME AROUND IN THE
CAPITAL.
CNN CHASING ME AROUND BACK
IN MY DISTRICT IN
CALIFORNIA.
ALWAYS WITH SMEARS.
ALWAYS WITH LIES.
ALWAYS WITH FAKE NEWS.
IT JUST HAPPENS THAT THIS
TIME THEY WENT WAY OVERBOARD
AND I'M NOT GOING TO TAKE IT
ANYMORE.
>> Sean: YOUR LAWSUIT GOES
ON TO CLAIM THEIR REPORT
CLAIMED THAT YOU MET WITH
UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR FIRED
SON OF A B THEY DID IT BY
QUID PRO QUO JOE VICTOR
SHOWINGEN IN VIENNA IN 2018
TO DIG UP DIRT ON HUNT AND
JOE BIDEN YOU DIDN'T GO
ANYWHERE NEAR THAT AREA NOR
DID YOU EVER METE WITH THE
UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR THAT
WAS FIRED BECAUSE OF JOE.
>> IT'S EVEN BETTER THAN
THAT I HAVE PICTURES OF
MYSELF IN BENGHAZI AND MALTA
AT THE TIME FRAME.
THIS IS SALUTE DEFINITION OF
FAKE NEWS.
RIGHT?
AND, LOOK, I HAVE MADE NO
SECRET THAT I WANT TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF WHO FUSION
GPS'S SOURCES WHO WERE THE
DEMOCRAT SOURCES IN UKRAINE?
WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING FOR
THOSE SOURCES FOR A VERY
LONG TIME.
I WILL TELL YOU I WASN'T IN
VIENNA AND DIDN'T MEET WITH
THIS GUY SHOKIN.
MAYBE I NEED.
TO SAY MAYBE I NEED TO REACH
OUT TO SHOKIN AND SEE WHAT
HE ACTUALLY HAS.
>> Sean: WHAT ABOUT THE
REPORTS TONIGHT THAT ARE
JUST BREAKING THAT REVEAL
MULTIPLE CALLS BETWEEN YOU,
THIS GUY PAR NEZ AND RUDY
GIULIANI.
MY SOURCES ARE TELLING ME
THAT THREE OF THE FOUR
SO-CALLED CALLS WERE JUST TO
GIULIANI AND ON PARNEZ'S
PHONE AND YOU AND UNDER A
MINUTE IS THAT TRUE.
>> EVEN BETTER THAN THAT
FIRST OF ALL, YOU HAVE TO
REMEMBER THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE ARE
THE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE AMERICAN AND
FOREIGNERS CONTACT US EVERY
SINGLE DAY WITH INFORMATION.
WE TAKE THAT INFORMATION.
YOU KNOW, WE SEE THEM
SOMEWHERE, WOULD LISTEN.
WE SAY CAN YOU GET THIS TO
THE APPROPRIATE LAWYER OR
STAFF MEMBER ON THE
COMMITTEE.
THE FACT THAT I KNOW RUDY
GIULIANI.
I HAVE KNOWN RUDY GIULIANI A
LONG TIME.
AND DURING THAT TIME, IF YOU
REMEMBER, THAT WAS RIGHT
WHEN ROBERT MUELLER
COMPLETELY BOMBED AND
INFLAMED OUT.
SO, I REMEMBER TALKING TO
RUDY GIULIANI.
AND WE WERE ACTUALLY
LAUGHING ABOUT HOW MUELLER
BOMBED OUT.
SO, YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW,
MAYBE THEY HAVE THE
RECORDINGS OF MY PHONE CALLS
WITH RUDY GIULIANI.
THEY ARE WELCOME TO PLAY
THEM.
BECAUSE EVERYTHING I SPOKE
WITH RUDY GIULIANI ABOUT IS
NOTHING THAT I WOULDN'T CARE
IF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE FOUND
OUT.
BUT THE FACT THAT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE USING THIS
ONCE AGAIN, WHAT ARE THEY
DOING?
THEY'RE LYING.
THEY COULD HAVE TOLD CNN
THAT I WASN'T IN VIENNA.
THEY HAVE THE RECORDS.
THEY WANTED THAT STORY TO BE
PRINTED.
>> Sean: DID YOU EVER TALK
TO THIS GUY LES PAR NEZ OR
WHOEVER THIS GUY IS?
IS.
>> IT'S POSSIBLE.
I HAVEN'T GONE THROUGH MY
PHONE RECORDS.
I DON'T RECALL THAT NAME.
I REMEMBER THE NAME NOW
BECAUSE HE HAS BEEN
INDICTED.
WHY WOULD CNN RELY ON
SOMEBODY LIKE THIS?
I WILL GO BACK AND CHECK MY
RECORDS BUT IT SEEMS
UNLIKELY I WILL BE TAKING
CALLS FROM RANDOM PEOPLE.
WE HAVE A STANDARD OPERATING
PROCEDURE.
YOU CALL MY OFFICE OR SEE ME
OUT ON THE STREET I WILL DO
MY JOB AND DO MY DUTY.
I WILL TAKE YOUR INFORMATION
AND GET IT TO THE
APPROPRIATE STAFF PERSON OR
THE APPROPRIATE AGENCY IN
THAT MATTER.
AND I WILL TELL YOU THIS:
THAT, YOU KNOW, ANYTHING
THAT WE HAVE FROM PAR NASA
AND HIS LAWYERS.
WHATEVER GAME THEY ARE UP,
TO WE WILL WORK DIRECTLY
WITH THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE GUYS
AREN'T JUST TRYING TO
OBSTRUCT JUSTICE, TO
OBSTRUCT OUR CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATION OR LIE TO
CONGRESS.
I CAN KAREN FEE YOU THAT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THESE GUYS
ARE UP TO.
BUT THE LONG ARM OF THE LAW